the Joe Rogan experience I've always
wanted to be good at chess that would be
a thing that would be like cool to tell
people like I'm really good at chess
really yeah yeah I guess so good thing
like you're really good at a lot of
other things so that's why this is one
of them once it's like universally
respected right meet a dude a good place
of chess like oh okay
Gary how's your chess game now checkers
on the other hand oh my god there's only
so many games and there's only so many I
love games I was in a day that's the
problem
I recently this is so silly my dear
landlord slash friend invited me
downstairs to play this game that was
created by the Rich Dad Poor Dad author
and yeah and it's I can't remember
I don't know what it's called but it it
[Music]
it's it's about it's a financial game
it's like a adult Monopoly okay you get
out of the rat race I'm always scared
when I play Monopoly you get out of the
rat race and then you go to the like big
dogs and it's very enlightening because
you're kind of like buying property and
then you're like making deals and
there's something about it that well I
did you read Rich Dad Poor Dad
no it's interesting it's it's an
interesting way to approach your
relationship with money
if you've ever struggled with it or
weren't sort of given a crash course on
how to handle it or not handle it like
what did you get out of it um I got that
like the power that money can have over
you is something to reconcile with you
know in a way that you can live a
healthier life and you know not
obviously in a consumerist society like
you kind of have this constant like I
need I need and you know all that stuff
but Rich Dad Poor Dad
I first of all I read half the book I
didn't read the whole
so I can't really like speak on the
entirety of it but it gave me a
different level of confidence that money
was taking from me you know like the war
as an artist like I chose the life to be
a musician I could have lived in
Cleveland and sold spaghetti and had a
comfortable life but it is family is a
great they have a great restaurant if
that ship has sailed because it's like
out of my immediate families hands but
at the time I've had many many moments
in my life where I was like should I
move home and just like ditch this music
thing because that would be so much
easier and money's been like this you
know you kind of have I've had a
rollercoaster and it can like rule my
sleep and rule my happiness in my
anxiety but when I read Rich Dad Poor
Dad and then in conjunction with this
board game I played with Russell it
really it's so funny it seems you know
what it seems like part of the whole
illusion of reality and obviously you
need money to survive but the the stock
that we put into it is pretty incredible
mmm you know and and like the things
that we think that we need in order to
to like satisfy us yes yes and and I
feel like there's this weird mind game
I'm always playing with it yeah like in
in terms of like getting to the next
level in my music career like it's gonna
take this much how you're gonna get you
know all that stuff but at the end of
the day I think when you sort of really
like release your white knuckles on on
the thing it all works itself out I know
that sounds pretty you know broad but I
think uh money is something that's
entangled into life yeah there's there's
great aspects to what you can do with
your money but it's entangled into your
life in a weird way there's like there's
what you currently can do right based on
your circumstances based on your life
your health your responsibilities
there's what you can do and there's what
what's like what's humanly possible for
you to do hmm and when you see people
that are making a lot of money and you
see that money the money starts you to
get you thinking that that's what you
should do yeah you should do that money
thing whatever that money is no no I
used to make less money now I make more
money and that makes more money then
even I make I got to do what that is to
get more money but then you do that you
realize oh but this isn't fun you know
most of my day is spent doing something
that's not enjoyable that's not what I
want to do so then it's what you want to
do what you can do what's possible and
what you want to do mm-hmm and they
don't always go together
sometimes what you can do is like you
have too much responsibilities and
you're you're always gonna feel
short-sighted by life because it's
random and it's crazy and it's chaos but
the money thing can trick you like if
you have well you have a certain amount
of money in the bank like Brian Cowen
said it best to me he's like once you go
to restaurant and you don't worry about
what food costs he goes everything else
is [ __ ] yeah I was like do you're
right yeah cuz that's that's when you're
free right when you know your rent is
paid you know your your gas is paid your
your car payments paid you're not
worried about it at all you could just
go eat let's go eat you don't care you
leave a nice fat tip thank you good
night bye that's when that's when you're
rich everything other than that is like
what are you doing are you just trying
to score points because that's what
we're doing we try to get the high score
[Music]
just passed pong super old-school dork
[ __ ] but that's what it's like yeah it's
like you know yeah the minute you stop
obsessing about it it stops becoming a
problem yeah in some ways I mean it
depends on your situation but yeah
for me it feels like this weird like
spiritual grapple or I'm just like like
once I chill out all the things start
yes always because you're more relaxed
if you're more relaxed you're better if
you're better you attract people that
want to do stuff with you yeah desperate
people
anxious people were the worst is angry
people people that are angry that
they've been [ __ ] over by the system
somehow and I'm not angry I will say
that and I feel really grateful for that
like with how hard I work in like trying
to get the things that I really want
I don't feel jaded or or you know
cynical about it I feel really excited
it's become gigantic it's gonna be
really romantic if that been these times
you gonna look back on me and Brad Pitt
right yeah there's something about these
days though like yeah I almost have to
appreciate them because when they're
gone they're gone forever
[Applause]